yeah I guess I have a lot of trouble
hearing physicians or politicians come
on TV or radio and say you know we don't
know what Medical Marijuana does
cognitively to to the brain of these
young kids and any parent who's got a
kid with epilepsy who's having seizures
we know what that does cognitively to
them to their brains in November 2013
the Barker family bought a home in
Colorado so their youngest daughter
Greta could have access to medical
marijuana currently medical marijuana is
illegal in their home state of Minnesota
we have a farm back in Minnesota so so I
need to go back pretty soon and get the
planting done but an older two girls
they're busy in school back in Minnesota
and Maria's got a nursing job back in
Minnesota for now Maria and Mark take
turns caring for Greta in Colorado
Greta actually was born perfectly
healthy great little girl and in five
months she just started randomly kind of
hysteria oddly we called physicians and
got her in for an MRI and testing and
she was basically diagnosed with
epilepsy at five months of age from then
until now her epilepsy is involved
evolved into what's called
lennox-gastaut syndrome and Linux
Castillo is a severe form of epilepsy
that involves several Loretto having
several different types of seizures so
she could have like four different kinds
of seizures each day this gal that
didn't even know my mom at all came up
to her and started asking about Greta I
could scratch with her at the time and
and she said so she has epilepsy doesn't
she
and I said yeah how did you know that
and so they just started talking on this
and this gal told her that the best
thing that had ever happened to her son
who has epilepsy was to run into Medical
Marijuana immediately when we heard of
it we were excited you know some people
say oh weren't you weirded out by that
are you kidding no any Greta had been to
the point where we had tried brain
surgeries we had tried so many
medicine failed so many things we're up
for anything we started researching it
online a lot and then as of August dr.
Sanjay Gupta had his his piece that
aired on CNN and basically we watched
that together as a family and we started
making plans a second after that show
was done gret is on a form of medical
marijuana called Charlotte's Web and it
comes in a liquid form it's mixed with
the olive oil it's high CBD which is I
can nab Adele mm-hmm yes and low THC low
low psychoactive part so she has no
chance of getting high whatsoever before
medical marijuana she has his team per
day probably since medical marijuana she
could have one per day she could have I
suppose a really bad day she could have
six you know back in Minnesota the
Legislature will likely vote on a
medical marijuana bill this week
reformers say they have enough votes to
legalize medical marijuana but governor
Mark Dayton may veto the bill in a
recent press conference that Dayton had
this advice for people like Greta who
could benefit from medical marijuana the
fact is that you can go on any city in
Minnesota I'm told and purse arowana and
possess less than an ounce of it and I
wasn't happy but the petty misdemeanors
it's traffic ticket this is a chance to
help the people that really need it and
need certain strains of medical
marijuana that we cannot get off the
street we can't just find it anywhere we
we've got to get it out here in Colorado
and if we pass this bill get it through
the legislature we'll be able to find a
way to get it to Minnesota during the
recent medical marijuana debate in
Minnesota governor Dayton's approval
rating dropped from 58 percent to 49
percent currently 68 percent of
Minnesotans approve of medical marijuana
it's time for Minnesota to pass this
it's we are not going on a limb here
there is you know now 21 other states
that
have said yes we we recognize the
benefits of this plant so we just we
just plead with the legislators and we
plead with Governor Dayton to to please
consider our daughter and in our family